le corps est entièrement ouvert
s vont être prélevés pesées disséquer et
répertoriés
[Musique]
quand vous prenez un peu de recul il y a
des fois vous dites mais c'est un moule
ignoble
c'est ignoble donc pour survivre à
l'ignoble il faut en faire un objet
sinon psychologiquement c'est pas
possible enfin ou alors c'est très
difficile ou alors on souffre
aujourd'hui dans une cour d'assises ce
que dit le médecin légiste est considéré
comme
sans bavure sans discussion
[Musique]
ces familles
sont contents de voir la dernière
personne qui s'est occupée en fait
compte de la rue des fins de voir un peu
notre notre tête et c'est vraiment
important pour eux qu'on leur explique
de quoi est mort
surtout quand c'est un petit peu violent
c'est important
[Musique]
l'avantage de faire de la médecine
légale l'avantage de voir des cadavres
Google journée de les découper d'étudier
leur cause de mort c'est que vous
comprenez la valeur de la vie
[Musique]
8 heures du matin quelque part dans la
campagne poitevine
[Applaudissements]
Michel sapanais se rend sur son lieu de
travail
une scène de crime
bonjour je suis le médecin légiste
d'accord allez-y merci mais une scène de
crime un peu particulière une
reconstitution dans les conditions du
réel c'est Michel sapinay qui a tout
organisé il a placé à l'abri des regards
un vrai squelette et une arme dans un
sous-bois le but de cette simulation est
de former les gendarmes de
l'identification criminelle et une
étudiante en médecine en 20 ans de
métiers Michel sapanay a travaillé sur
des centaines de scènes de crimes
passionnés par son métier il en a écrit
un livre à chaque fois il suit les mêmes
règles ne pas se précipiter s'imprégner
des lieux moi j'ai une organisation en
trois cercles que j'ai massé j'arrive
près de ma forêt c'est mon premier
cercle quel type de forêt qu'est-ce que
je peux y trouver comme animaux est-ce
qu'il y a des sont liés qui sont
susceptibles d'être passé par là bonjour
quel type de terrain est-ce que j'ai
c'est des feuillus c'est des conifères
est-ce que la terre est acide est-ce
qu'elle est calcaire voilà ça c'est mon
premier cercle et puis là dedans je
rajoute la météo de ces derniers jours
arrivés sur les lieux de son assistante
et surtout de Lolita sa stagiaire en
dernier année de médecine
l'objectif de la journée lui apprendre à
travailler sur une scène de crime et lui
donner l'envie de devenir légiste elle a
encore tout à apprendre le directeur
d'enquête nous a prévenu il y a une
heure à peu près de ça comme quoi il y
avait un fronter qui a découvert un
squelette là où il y a les fléchages
et les numéros et puis
on n'a pas fouillé encore welcran nu
elle est encore habillée on a retrouvé
des chaussures et là on a trouvé une
arme là on essaie de dégager un peu donc
on pense qu'il y a eu des erreur une
bagarre ou une un truc comme ça enfin
c'est pas naturel quoi c'est pas naturel
il vaut mieux éviter les gendarmes de
l'identification criminelle viennent de
terminer leur première constatation
découverte du corps et marquage des
indices au sol c'est au tour du médecin
légiste d'entrer en scène gant
combinaison sur bottes masques il doit
se protéger entièrement ne pas polluer
la scène de crime
premier conseil à Lolita
donc le but de tout ça c'est éviter
d'amener des indices et en particulier
votre ADN sur la scène de crime ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut pas que je vois vos
cheveux
[Musique]
mon deuxième cercle je
m'approche c'est le bosquet proprement
dit les traces
le chemin vous avez vu le sentier
ou cet environnement je le regarde
est-ce qu'il y a une anomalie
particulière là dedans
[Applaudissements]
et puis mon troisième cercle c'est la
scène de crime telle qualité
balisée donc par les gendarmes qui elle
effectivement c'est là un carré de 10
mètres par 10
une scène de crimes balisée
indispensable pour repousser les curieux
il y a la fascination morbide tout
simple
parce qu'il y a pas le cadavre le
cadavre attire attire les gens
l'accident sur une bordure à bord de
route c'est une voiture est sur le toit
beaucoup de gens vont s'arrêter pour
regarder au loin pas forcément
s'impliquer mais ça va il y a une
fascination naturelle pour ça ce qui est
pas notre cas moi je fais ça plus pour
apporter des réponses surtout dans le
cadre des découvertes de cadavres on a
quand même des on a une victime
forcément mais on a des gens autour on a
de la famille et c'est important pour
eux de savoir ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'il faut que la vérité soit le dans le
cas d'un meurtre il faut que la vérité
soit mais il faut surtout aussi que les
personnes puissent faire leur deuil et
je pense qu'on a une responsabilité
importante à ce niveau là donc moi c'est
dur quand je sais pas quand je quand
j'ai pas trouvé ou là ça me pose des
problèmes après c'est c'est des
questions techniques donc
on fait abstraction des sentiments
personnels et puis on s'attarde sur ce
qui est technique quoi une paire de
lunettes avec un verre droit absent
indice 5
[Applaudissements]
une chaussure
rien ne doit leur échapper chaussures
vêtements armes le moindre indice est
fondamental pour la suite de l'enquête
c'est
un pistolet
semi automatique sous le regard attentif
des gendarmes et de son étudiante Michel
sapinay prélève tout ce qu'il trouve et
le moindre indice est systématiquement
pris en photo pour l'instruction
les restes l'extrémité inférieure d'un
avant bras
[Applaudissements]
puisqu'on a radius et cubitus donc je
pense que le vraisemblablement la main
doit être quelque part là-dedans
et ensuite donc la tête
donc c'est ça qu'ils ont ils ont vu en
premier
donc là on a le crâne
on va voir dans quelle orientation il
est
vous comprenez Lolita en intervient sur
la scène une fois que les tics
techniciens d'investigation criminelle
sont passées ils ont tout repéré tout ce
qui est autour du corps
donc là ils ont eu la gentillesse de
nous attendre pour mettre les indices
dans les dans les sacs mais aussi bien
et j'aurais pu le faire l'avantage c'est
que on situe parfaitement la position de
chaque élément et l'arme en particulier
donc on a des lunettes assez loin une
chaussure une arme et encore
voilà donc après on verra
une fois qu'on aura dégagé tout ça
comment on peut intégrer un scénario
là-dedans
[Musique]
c'est intéressant d'avoir les hypothèses
des enquêteurs ça vous permet de prendre
le contre-pied éventuellement que ce
soit comme jeu ou comme technique parce
que si vous avez deux directions
d'enquête forcément on a une chance de
trouver une vérité et puis pour faire ça
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup plus
informatif d'être sur les lieux que
d'être seulement dans sa salle de
toxique pour moi ça fait partie de
l'activité du médecin légiste et
effectivement c'est extrêmement
enrichissant
et agréable
la difficulté c'est de pas perdre dedans
donc il est vraisemblable qu'elles sont
tombées comme très souvent donc il me
faudra un sac papier
parce que tout ce qui est corporel donc
il contient de l'ADN il faut pouvoir
préserver cette ADN et de préférence on
met ça dans des sacs en papier kraft qui
permettent l'humidité de s'évacuer voilà
donc
ah oui effectivement
ça c'est des dents qui sont tombés après
la mort donc il faudra les récupérer
là-dedans
je vais le maxillaire supérieur qui est
parti en morceaux maintenant que les
indices sont répertoriés Michel sapanay
peut commencer à toucher au corps
la difficulté de prélever le squelette
en entier sans perdre le moindre
fragment d'os à chaque scène de crime
son environnement il faut savoir
s'adapter ici pas de coton-tige mais une
bêche alors la solution que j'ai adoptée
c'est la suivante
c'est de passer
suffisamment profond sous le corps
donc dégager bon évidemment là je pense
que je vais emporter quelques végétaux
mais c'est pas grave
mettez la planche par exemple
on essaie de redresser la planche
voilà très bien
bon là on a de la chance
quelque sorte on allait les bas qui nous
ont tout gardé
voilà
tout ça on va l'emporter
le squelette placé sur une planche en
bois sera transférée au CHU pour faire
son autopsie donc ce qui serait
peut-être bien c'est que vous passiez un
petit coup de poêle à frire
par dessus histoire de voir qu'il y a
pas de bijoux on sait jamais dernière
vérification avant de quitter les lieux
un travail minutieux rien n'est laissé
au hasard
c'est un vrai travail de fourmi en fait
[Musique]
faut trouver des auteurs quoi le ou les
auteurs prendre des heures et des heures
des jours et des jours les heures ça
serait bien pour nous c'est plutôt des
jours
mais non il y a un gros travail de fait
sur le terrain mais il y a un énorme
travail de fait également celle de
toxique et des fois on revient c'est pas
parce qu'on a prélevé le corps qu'on va
libérer le territoire on va faire garder
le territoire par les gendarmes tant
qu'on a pas trouvé des solutions
expliquez les raisons de la mort
c'est la mission première du médecin
légiste
l'intervention du médecin légiste dans
l'enquête c'est dans les premières
heures
c'est ses propres constatations et c'est
aussi évidemment ce que lui demande le
juge d'instruction
et il y a une affaire que connaît bien
Dominique verdayan
une affaire dans laquelle les premières
constatations et l'autopsie ont été
bâclées il y a aujourd'hui une affaire
criminelle
qu'on cherche encore à résoudre
alors quelle date de 84
on espère trouver la solution dans l'ADN
c'est l'affaire Grégory au commencement
de l'enquête il y avait deux médecins
légistes dont le docteur Pagel c'est
elle qui a pratiqué l'autopsie de
Grégory il portait un bonnet un anorak
il avait une cordelette autour du cou
des mains et des chevilles les liens
n'étaient pas du tout serrés le juge
Lambert lui aussi était là il ne voulait
pas du tout qu'on fasse les prélèvements
accusent le docteur Pagel ça nous a
surpris on a insisté on a juste obtenu
l'autorisation de prélever du sang et
les poumons en émettant de faire tous
les prélèvements on a réduit les
possibilités de faire la lumière
enchaîne le professeur le Breton
l'autopsie du petit Grégory a été mal
faite alors elle a été mal faite
peut-être à cause du médecin légiste
mais aussi à cause du jus d'instruction
qui lui a donné une mission beaucoup
trop vague 25 ans après l'effet on ne
sait toujours pas si le petit Grégory
est mort noyé dans les eaux de la
Vologne ou s'il est mort avant et on ne
connaît toujours pas le coupable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il aura fallu plus de 2h à Michel
sapinelle pour expliquer à son étudiante
sa technique d'enquête sur le terrain
[Applaudissements]
les gendarmes de l'identification
criminelle libère les lieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le moment où le légiste peut
commencer son enquête médicale
[Musique]
enquêter pour comprendre
apprendre et répondre à des questions
physiques et philosophiques c'est ce qui
a donné naissance à la médecine légale
pourquoi n'est la médecine légale sans
doute pour expliquer des choses
extraordinaires et peut-être
l'interrogation de l'homme par rapport à
des questions qui au départ dans
l'Antiquité en tout cas étaient
attribués au divin
et cette interrogation qui était déjà un
début de la science est-ce totalement
quelque chose de magique ce qui se passe
ou peut-on avoir une explication c'est
cette curiosité qui anime la médecine
légale
je fais la médecine légale donc je vois
du vivant je vois des morts
approcher la réalité et percer le
mystère qui entoure le corps et le crime
jusqu'à maintenant les autopsies ont
connu au cours de ces derniers siècles
un développement constant
et donc si les ordres on a appris à
briser le tabou de la mort
et du corps la première autopsie
judiciaire on va dire en France en tout
cas que cet embrasse pareil directement
chirurgien du roi et ce roi François 1er
homme de la Renaissance homme de
curiosité
va en avant mais c'est aussi la période
où Vésale en Italie fait les premières
autopsies c'est la période où Leonard de
Vinci fait ce fameux schéma corporel
que l'on utilise toujours en médecine et
c'est la première description des corps
cette première interrogation une très
une autopsie très célèbre qui a lieu
c'est celle qui se fait après le tournoi
ou Henri II est blessé mortellement par
une lance qui lors d'un tournoi
occasionne des lésions crâniennes
encéphalique c'est une des premières
raisons et on a dans le judiciaire
énormément d'éléments c'est le début
c'est le début de l'arrivée de la preuve
dans le judiciaire alors que nous
n'oublions pas à l'époque il reposait
beaucoup sur la question
c'est à dire la torture les éléments
d'aveu l'aveu est toujours été très en
avant on va vers des preuves et non plus
simplement l'aveu de culpabilité
des médecins légistes des salles
d'autopsie qui sentent la javel
une lumière lugubre
un métier à part qui fascine autant
qu'il est frais il doit pas y avoir de
limites au moyen utilisé parce qu'il
s'agit d'une personne c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que ça devienne un objet
d'étude le temps de l'autopsie c'est un
objet d'étude une fois que le toxique
fini on le restaure on le lave on le
maquille on le rhabille et on le
réintègre en quelque sorte alors pas
dans la communauté des vivants parce que
là c'est un petit peu trop tard mais en
lui redonne sa qualité de personne mais
entre les deux faut absolument que j'en
fasse un objet d'étude sinon enfin une
autopsie c'est extrêmement agressif je
rajoute aux violences du de l'auteur
je rajoute alors c'est pas des violences
mais je rajoute mes propres mutilations
je l'ouvre complètement j'ouvre toutes
les cavités je prends tous les organes
c'est
la limite quand vous prenez un peu de
recul il y a des fois vous dites mais
c'est un boulot ignoble
c'est ignoble donc pour survivre à
l'ignoble il faut en faire un objet
sinon psychologiquement c'est pas
possible enfin ou alors c'est très
difficile ou alors on souffre j'ai pas
envie de souffrir à cause de mon métier
[Applaudissements]
l'unité médico-légale du CHU de Bordeaux
et l'une des plus importantes en France
plus de 500 autopsie ils sont pratiqués
chaque année depuis 1996 Sophie gronde
dirige cette unité femme au parcours
atypique elle cumule les diplômes de
droit de sciences et de médecine
sophie grombe est une figure
emblématique de la médecine légale en
France pendant deux ans elle a travaillé
pour le Tribunal pénal international sur
les charniers au Kosovo pour identifier
les squelettes une expérience marquante
pour cette femme alors jeune médecin
légiste Maryline des chouwer forêt je
vous mets le courrier et vous avez ces
coordonnées les affaires fourniraient
Pierrot le Fou Allègre le gendarme
Chabert c'était elle
Sophie grond se prédestiné à une
carrière de commissaire de police mais
c'est assez naturellement qu'elle s'est
tournée vers la médecine légale pour
elle c'est avant tout un métier
d'enquêteur honnêtement je pense que
quand on fait médecine c'est pas a
priori pour aller découper son prochain
parce que bon c'est très prosaïque mais
c'est un peu la première image que ça
renvoie c'est l'aboutissement d'un long
cheminement d'une double culture quand
même c'est à dire qu'en fait j'ai fait
médecine légale parce que j'étais
médecin et juriste et non l'inverse on
me dit souvent ah ben oui vous avez fait
du droit vous êtes médecin légiste c'est
normal en fait non non pas du tout c'est
parce que j'étais médecin et juriste que
j'ai fait de la médecine légale mais
c'est passionnant je regrette pas
[Musique]
mais attendu ma chérie comment
aujourd'hui Sophie grombe a réuni une
vingtaine de médecins légistes de la
région Aquitaine il travaille souvent
seul sans les moyens techniques du CHU
il faut donc les remettre à niveau
l'objectif est de mettre au point un
protocole pour harmoniser les méthodes
de prélèvement pendant une autopsie
c'est une phase clé la moindre erreur
peut avoir des conséquences judiciaires
graves la veille un motard a été amenée
à l'unité médico-légale décédée sur la
voie publique sans témoin son autopsie
est obligatoire pour l'identification du
corps et pour déterminer s'il n'a pas
fait un malaise préalable à son accident
étape numéro 1
le corps doit être entièrement scanner
sous le contrôle de Sophie gronde c'est
une autre légiste du CHU de Bordeaux qui
dirige l'autopsie
il y a une luxation infractualisation de
la clavicule gauche
dans la main aussi elle facture luxation
du deuxième métacarpien
une remise à niveau pour certains pour
d'autres l'occasion d'échanger des
conseils
parce que vous vous mettez pas de devant
un petit coucou
[Musique]
par le Secours
étape numéro 2 l'examen du corps
les nages beige à rayures encolure en
vêtement lésion externe ecchymose
coupure le moindre détail est mentionné
dans un rapport d'autopsie
façon cuire alors comment tu sais que
c'est pas du cul parce que
moi
les choses sérieuses commencent
changement de ton
moment où il faut faire parler le corps
pour déterminer s'il s'agit d'une
hémorragie d'un accident n'est pas
d'ivresse ou d'un arrêt cardiaque
il faut passer en revue une à une toutes
les hypothèses
tout le monde a l'air décontracté en
apparence c'est vrai que dans le métier
de médecin légiste enfin à la dose ou
nous l'exercice à Bordeaux c'est-à-dire
du temps plein ou nous faisons que de la
violence effectivement il faut être
assez équilibré et avoir autre chose et
des dérivatifs je crois que c'est
important sinon on peut pas on tient pas
c'est très dur on voit en permanence je
dis souvent c'est affreux ça les
méchants en permanence
une fois lavée l'examen interne commence
entièrement ouvert
tous les organes vont être prélevés
pesées disséquer et répertorié moment
clé de la formation c'est souvent à ce
moment-là que les erreurs interviennent
c'est aller chercher en iliaque du sang
périphérique c'est la première chose
avant de faire quoi que ce soit avant de
faire ses l'estomac avant de faire quoi
que ce soit et le dosage quantitatif se
fait sur ça
elle fait le screening sur le reste et
le quantitatif et tout la toxico qui est
faite au dessus du diaphragme je peux
vous dire que les contre expertises sont
légion et moi la bile c'est 17 17
millilitres de billes environ 1000
contre expertises médicales seraient
pratiquées chaque année et la rate 149
la machine judiciaire doit alors se
remettre en route c'est souvent
fastidieux et refaire une autops Ie peut
s'avérer compliquer
un petit peu quand même
et donc vous filtrer le contenu de
restaurant parce que c'est pour
retrouver des médicaments des comprimés
éventuellement
on le pèse
puis on le filtre tu regardes ça je vais
regarder
en toxicoot des éléments
on propose une technique
n'oubliez pas quand même que quand vous
avez le moindre doute sur du lancer ou
du post mortel il faut laver on la veut
pas assez il faut laver laver laver
laver ça ne craint rien vous pouvez
mettre tout sous l'eau et si ça se dit
tout enfin l'anté mortelle se dissout
allez on y va
l'autopsie a duré plus d'une heure une
heure d'analyse de prélèvement une heure
pour connaître l'origine du décès en
fait un banal accident ce moteur est
mort sur le coup
le corps a été meurtri disséqué découpé
un spectacle pénible pour le commun des
mortels est-ce que vous avez déjà la
hantise de vous retrouver justement à la
place de ces personnes là non j'ai
jamais pensé
j'ai jamais pensé mais
bon moi ça me dérangerait pas parce que
je trouve que c'est important pour ceux
qui restent de savoir de quoi est décédé
une personne c'est il y a un gros
sentiment de culpabilité chez les
personnes qui entourent un des femmes je
le sais parce que je reçois beaucoup de
famille et je vois bien que les familles
sont visiblement heureuses entre
guillemets bien sûr de rencontrer la
dernière personne qui a touché à l'être
cher et qui est capable de leur dire de
quoi il est mort comment ont été les
dernières heures de la vie je pense que
c'est très important bon le monde une
fois qu'on est mort on n'est plus là
pour savoir mais pour ceux qui restent
je crois que c'est important on arrive à
faire abstraction de de cette vision du
corps et surtout de se dire qu'est-ce
qu'elle qu'est-ce que la personne a
ressenti parce que c'est ça en fait qui
qui est un petit peu troublant parce que
c'est un acte technique et que on
cherche la manifestation de la vérité on
cherche les codes de la mort on cherche
un trajet de balle voilà donc on est
méticuleux dans notre acte technique et
on voit pas la personne en fait
et dès les familles à faire leur deuil
déterminer les causes de la mort aider à
trouver des coupables c'est la partie de
la médecine légale la plus connue mais
dans certains cas les légistes
travaillent aussi avec les vivants
Sophie gomb a créé le Covin 1999 le
premier centre d'accueil en urgence des
victimes d'agression
le Koba bonjour simple bagarre violence
conjugale viol agression sur mineur afin
d'éviter la lourdeur des procédures
toutes ces personnes blessées
physiquement et psychologiquement sont
reçus par des assistantes sociales des
psychologues des juristes et des
médecins légistes
[Musique]
fait agresser en sortant de boîte de
nuit la médecin légiste le reçoit pour
un examen poussé et faire ses premières
constatations
la victime doit raconter dans les
moindres détails ce qu'il s'est passé
pendant l'agression
parce que c'est les gens que vous
connaissiez ou pas
et donc ce qui s'est passé c'est que
quelqu'un m'a agressé
sans motif
S
[Applaudissements]
de l'entretien ce jeune homme aura entre
les mains une interruption temporaire de
travail pour son employeur une pièce
fondamentale qui l'aidera en cas de
poursuite judiciaire
ok l'idée qui va pousser à créer le Cova
et que la médecine légale est une
médecine d'expertise auxiliaire de
justice on pèse on mesure on écrit des
rapports au kilomètre c'est un peu
déshumanisé et nous avions face à nous
nous l'avons toujours une population en
souffrance parfois même désespérée et je
trouvais qu'on pouvait être beaucoup
plus utile et soignant aussi parce que
pour être médecin légiste on en est pas
moins médecin tous les lundis l'équipe
se réunit pour faire le point sur les
dossiers de la semaine passée
elle elle est étonnante dans son
comportement parce qu'elle n'hésite pas
à redonner alors que souvent quand on
pense qu'il y a un danger on les redonne
pas souvent des dossiers très complexes
comme les cas d'agression sur mineur
quand est-ce qu'elle doit donner les
réunions nécessaires pour échanger les
points de vue et mettre en place un
suivi social et psychologique
pourquoi ça a été barré parce qu'il
n'est pas venu TB c'est pareil
en fait donc c'est une jeune fille qui
qui a pu se saisir d'une d'un séjour en
colonie vacance pour pour révéler une
animatrice de la colonie qu'elle était
donc maltraité physiquement dans un
premier temps par ses parents donc suite
à cette suite assez révélations il y a
une mesure avec un suivi éducatif qui a
été mis en place et donc fin début
janvier elle a pu par rapport au lien
qu'elle avait écrit avec l'éducatrice se
révéler les les viols qu'elle
subissaient depuis l'âge de 8 non 4 ans
ça commence à l'âge de 4 ans voilà donc
elle a pu en parler éducatrice donc elle
a été il y a eu une un placement au
foyer dans un foyer donc voilà donc elle
parle de voilà de elle parle de viol de
son frère et de son frère c'est trois
frères voilà et de son oncle du côté
maternel
et ses frères et sont plus âgés
24 et 20 ans
c'est que elle est très inquiète pour sa
petite sœur de 8 ans donc voilà
la famille
mais on la protège pas plus du capteur à
domicile des dossiers compliqués comme
celui-là ils en traitent 4000 par an
la grande vient de faire
retour à Poitiers
dans les sous-sols du CHU le service de
la médecine légale le service de Michel
sapinay
pour demain matin
[Musique]
d'accord vous avez au scanner là il est
20h un corps vient d'arriver
comme tous les cadavres qui doivent être
autopsiés ils doivent passer au scanner
problème la machine est au deuxième
étage le service de médecine légale au
sous-sol alors il faut être le plus
discret possible
une petite partie de cache-cache
commence dans les couloirs de l'hôpital
il ne faut pas être vu les vivants d'un
côté les morts de l'autre chacun à sa
place
vous vous cachez là oui pourquoi par
rapport au vivant
[Musique]
impressionnant c'est mal vécu au sein de
l'hôpital
parce que les médecins ont un rapport à
la mort qui est particulier différent
des autres médecins il est certain que
il y a un rapport particulier avec la
vie et avec la mort les deux
le définir c'est très difficile ce que
je sais c'est que
[Musique]
ça permet de s'accoutumer à l'idée de sa
propre mort
ça permet de prendre conscience de la
valeur de la vie au cas où on l'aurait
oublié et ça relativise considérablement
tous les événements qui n'ont pas de
gravité réelle
[Musique]
autour de la chambre froide
une odeur un peu particulière
indéfinissable pour certains
[Musique]
mais reconnaissable pour d'autres
là ce sont encore plus très fier de
trois semaines
le putréfié à une odeur qui varie avec
les étapes ça peut être le bord Rance
après c'est un petit peu stylé ouest et
puis après ça s'aggrave très nettement
comme ici vous avez encore à supporter
oui c'est l'habitude
on met pas les petits produits enfin moi
je mets pas les petits produits j'aime
bien garder mon odorat et pouvoir m'en
servir si besoin
dans ces cas-là maintenant j'ai plus
besoin
allez on ferme
[Musique]
le lendemain matin Michel sapanay
continue la formation de Lolita
l'étudiante en médecine ils vont
autopsier le squelette retrouver dans
les bois pendant la reconstitution de
scènes de crime
le but aujourd'hui c'est d'apprendre à
Lolita à retrouver l'identité d'un
squelette
[Musique]
je reste sur nos indices
voilà donc le but
trouver
les éléments qui peuvent intéresser les
enquêteurs dans cet ensemble qui nous
vient des bois est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué de trouver l'origine d'un
décès sur un squelette ou sur un cadavre
récent
squelette
ça va dépendre si on a un enfoncement de
la boîte crânienne on peut
imaginer un traumatisme crânien mais
s'il y a pas une trace sur l'os
on n'aura pas la cause on peut avoir une
plaie par coup de couteau une plaie par
balle sans qui aucune trace sur les eaux
par exemple une femme qui serait
étranglée
le larynx au bout de trois ou quatre ans
il y en a plus c'est une structure
plutôt cartilagineuse donc la
strangulation disparaîtra les traces de
la strangulation disparaîtront
tout ceci on va gentiment il est
possible de faire parler un squelette et
trouver un maximum d'indices pour
élaborer un scénario criminel et
déterminer un âge et
j'ai plus rien des mains et des pieds
les ossements sont bien conservés mais
éparpillés
première difficulté
reconstituer le squelette
cela peut prendre plusieurs heures
dans cet état il faut combien de temps
plusieurs années
je suis sur
je pense au moins trois ans
toute la terre retrouvée sur les lieux
du crime doit être tamisée pour
retrouver le moindre fragment qui s'est
détaché
[Musique]
alors
on va refaire le tri après il y a du
travail
puisqu'il va falloir
étudier chaque os remettre chaque os à
sa place remonter un squelette complet
là aussi je suis sur une chemise de nuit
à large échancrure
je peux avoir une balle dans le corps
sans avoir
une chemise de nuit de vieilles dames un
premier indice ne rien oublier ne rien
laisser au hasard c'est toute la
difficulté de ce travail
au service de la justice c'est assez
enquêteur de l'ombre d'apporter le
maximum de réponses ça peut être utile
de le donner aux enquêteurs
une demi-journée ou une journée entière
quand vous êtes au procès que
vous arrivez aux assises que vous faites
votre déposition d'experts que vous
éclairez tout ce qui a été dit avant en
particulier la façon dont l'accusé
relatait les faite quand vous montrez
que ce qu'il dit
tout à fait inexact quand vous prouvez
ces contradictions par rapport à ce que
vous dites corps on a un rôle
effectivement qui est majeur donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire aussi attention
à ce qu'on dit
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est ce qu'il y avait près de
la tête
voilà très bien c'est quoi ça
c'est important pour éliminer une
strangulation voilà Aurélie minet une
strangulation exactement
donc là j'ai un demi maxillaire
l'accélère gauche et là j'ai l'autre
demi maxillaire l'accélère droit
et de l'ensemble ça c'est intéressant
parce que cette personne
a une couronne
un soin antérieur ici
bon on fera des radios pour voir s'il y
a des soins qu'on ne verrait pas
ce style par exemple ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une résine donc ce sont des
techniques
classiques donc ça veut dire qu'elle a
un dossier dentaire là il manque dedans
mais ça c'est des chutes mortelles
donc
les alvéoles sont parfaitement visibles
c'est pas une extraction hantée mortem
puisque à ce moment-là on a un caillot
on a des du tissu de fibrose à
l'intérieur qui va boucher l'alvéole en
quelques semaines ce qu'il va falloir
reconstruire refaire ses seins
là on récupère une hauteur de visage
c'est à partir de ça un peu
effectivement
faire des évaluations
de portrait
grâce à plusieurs indices les habits
l'étude des ossements et la dentition
Michel Sapanet pourrait facilement
retrouver l'identité de la victime
[Musique]
dans certains cris mystérieux le médecin
légiste et le seul à pouvoir donner une
identité à un corps
1991 l'affaire Simone Weber des frais la
chronique cette femme est soupçonnée
d'avoir fait disparaître son amant
Bernard etiet dont on est sans nouvelles
mais pas de corps donc pas de crime
jusqu'à ce que quelques mois plus tard
un pêcheur tombe sur une valise avec à
l'intérieur un tronc très difficile à
identifier
vraiment plus que le corps il y a plus
la tête il y a plus les bras le corps
est un peu en état déjà décomposition
avancée donc le corps est confié un
médecin légiste et on compare évidemment
ce qu'il constate sur le trou
et ce qu'on peut avoir du dossier
médical
de Bernard laitier calque et radio à
l'appui le professeur coudan établit son
diagnostic il existe une concordance
très grande entre les radios de Bernard
et thier et celle du tronc européen dans
la valise et donc on est dans un espèce
de mécano qu'on va totalement d'ailleurs
reconstruire à l'audience madame Weber
dira oui oui on essaye de de
s'approprier ce Tron ah oui parce que ce
trou effectivement le médecin légiste
dit c'est celui de Bernard routier et
donc c'est évidemment l'argument qui à
la fois évidemment pendant l'instruction
va être un élément à charge contre
Simone Weber et c'est un des éléments
qui va être à charge pour sa
condamnation être accompagnée à 20 ans
de réclusion criminelle
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui dans une cour
d'assise ce que dit le médecin légiste
est considéré comme
s'en bavure sans discussion ce qui me
plaît le plus c'est redonner de
l'humanité assez victime et
effectivement
participer à la sanction du coupable
lorsqu'on a ou participé au contraire au
fait qu'il soit innocent
[Musique]
mais quand l'identification est
impossible en dernier recours ont fait
appel en France aux gendarmes de l'IRCGN
un Rosny-sous-Bois en région parisienne
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale c'est ici que des
ossements sont envoyés de toute la
France pour expertise au département
entrepologie thanatologie sa mission
identifier les corps et rechercher des
causes et circonstances des décès
le médecin chef Yves chouliart fait
partie de l'équipe d'experts il est
médecin légiste son laboratoire unique
en France ses spécialisé dans la
reconstruction faciale à partir des
crânes
pour la reconstruction faciale
entendons-nous bien c'est une méthode
qu'on utilise en dernier recours dans
toutes les autres techniques
d'identification l'aboutissent pas et
quand notamment on n'a pas d'éléments
comparatifs on n'a pas de piste on va
tenter
par la reconstitution faciale
d'approcher le visage réel de la
personne de manière à ce que ce visage
soit diffusé par les enquêteurs ou par
les médias et que quelqu'un dise oui ça
me rappelle une personne que je connais
et donc ça va relancer l'enquête on a on
a des retours positifs tout à fait alors
je sais pas si j'ai pas des exemples à
vous montrer que je retrouve le dossier
sourire
voilà donc
voilà le la numérisation du crâne avec
là ici il y a quelques standards
d'épaisseur qui ont été positionnés un
visage de synthèse qui a été établi en
fonction déjà des données
anthropométriques et ce visage de
synthèse est déformé vous pouvez venir
se plaquer sur le crâne avec les
standards d'épaisseur et voilà ici
le résultat obtenu ensuite lorsque le
résultat est obtenu on peut faire un
habillage avec des cheveux etc parce
qu'on a un logiciel de portrait robot
qui nous permet donc d'affiner les
résultats alors voilà quelques exemples
de réussite de par cette méthode donc la
diffusion
de ces portraits donc si c'est un homme
si c'est une femme a permis donc de
retrouver ces personnes
on n'a pas l'impression de refaire
parfaitement le visage de une personne
mais il y a quand même des éléments qui
permettent donc à quelqu'un qui connaît
cette personne de
d'être interpellé de dire oui ça me
rappelle quelqu'un que je connais ça
peut être voilà après on vérifie par
d'autres techniques un résultat proche
de la réalité
une méthode qui a révolutionné le
travail des médecins légistes pour les
enquêtes les plus compliquées comme dans
les catastrophes naturelles les
tremblements de terre le tsunami de 2002
où les accidents d'avion comme au
Venezuela ou 152 Martiniquais ont été
tués
quelle est l'affaire qui a été le plus
compliqué pour vous psychologiquement il
y en a deux il y a l'affaire du tunnel
du Mont-Blanc qui était très compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre parce que c'est
vraiment des conditions on était en
plein milieu du tunnel à 6 km de la
sortie donc fallait travailler dans le
noir dans les conditions difficiles ça
fait très long il fallait identifier les
véhicules dans le tunnel pour avoir une
idée de qui pouvait se trouver dans ces
véhicules et donc à la spécialiste du
département véhicule qui sont allés avec
nous pour d'abord identifier les
véhicules carbonisés sur les 40
personnes décédées 5 ont été
formellement ident
ifiés les hommes de la police
scientifique et les médecins légistes
éprouvent les pires difficultés à mettre
un nom sur les corps
imaginez ce qui peut rester
quand la température a dépassé plusieurs
centaines de degrés pendant 24 heures ou
48 heures
de constatation à l'intérieur du tunnel
pour pouvoir retrouver et sortir les
corps du tunnel ensuite il a fallu 15
autres jours d'examen des corps pour
arriver aux identifications et l'autre
affaire qui a été compliqué c'est une
des dernières affaires du Venezuela donc
un crash d'avion près de Marrakech
était extrêmement abîmé avec des relevés
dans des conditions très difficiles et
il a fallu faire de l'ADN sur tous les
corps pour arriver à les identifier ça a
été très long très difficile donc c'est
les deux affaires les plus
qui ont été pour nous techniquement les
plus les plus durs
ça permet de rendre aux familles les
corps qui leur appartiennent avec
certitude
et puis quand les personnes retrouvent
le corps qui appartiennent donc elles
peuvent entraver leur travail de deuil
je crois que c'est attendre elle est
abominable et nous on véritablement on
essaie de la réduire
[Musique]
les légistes ces experts qui trouvent
des solutions à tout ou presque sont
maintenant les stars du petit écran
leur univers fascine et les producteurs
l'ont bien compris
les séries les experts Bones et ris
cartonne
[Musique]
Benjamin Dupont Julien est un des
producteurs de RIS Police Scientifique
bien une série qui suit les
investigations d'une équipe d'enquêteurs
une fois par semaine il réunit les
auteurs pour peaufiner des scénarios
parfois inspirés
donc 14 juillet
[Musique]
tu as forcément un char d'assaut qui
expose d'une bagnole dans le civil tu as
une armée de militaires qui verrouille
le truc alors que tu fais venir tu fais
rêver les flics quelque part avant les
militaires en réalité ils sont sur place
tu vois ils sont en colonne de char les
uns les autres tu as un char qui
s'échappe qui fasse une bagnole les
autres ils mettent à trois heures
arriver quoi ils arrêtent les chiens il
est son il bloque la scène la scène de
crime est à nous stop la police
militaire arrive il y a les officiers
qui débarquent sur le champ ils sont à 2
mètres de là sur les Champs-Élysées ils
vont débarquer dans la minute et quand
les flics débarquent les filles
débarquent après ok on a des on a le
crime on a des gens qui ont des mobiles
pour faire ça on a des gens qui s'aiment
qui séparent et tout mais sur le fond
des choses moi j'y crois pas à
l'histoire encore l'objectif est d'être
le plus réaliste possible avec comme
seul contrainte faire en 50 minutes ce
que les techniciens font en plusieurs
semaines
je crois que c'est séries là que ce soit
les experts ou risques et finalement une
une déclinaison à la française de cette
thématique là qui disent qu'il est
décédé de de trouver les de résoudre des
crimes par la preuve et de
d'approcher la mort de manière un peu
scientifique c'est quelque chose de
rassurant ce qui rassure vachement les
gens moi je pense c'est de se dire ah
c'est super de se dire qu'aujourd'hui la
science peut tout résoudre la science
peut soigner les gens donc on est la
preuve typique et la science peut
trouver des coupables quel que soit les
mecs que je mets à la tête du risque ou
qui vont inquiéter la science va trouver
le coupable pour les aider les auteurs
ont un référent médecin légiste et
entomologiste le professeur Gosset à
Lille
donc on l'utilise en consultant en amont
pour trouver des sujets on aime bien
aller déjeuner avec lui ou l'inviter sur
le plateau pour discuter avec lui puis
il nous raconte sa vie et puis il suffit
d'appuyer sur le bouton Play et puis on
l'écoute parler pendant des heures et
puis on ressort avec plein d'idées c'est
un vrai bonheur et puis sinon quand on a
appris nous écrit des textes et qu'on a
des scènes d'autopsie on lui soumet les
on lui soumet les scènes pour voir avec
lui les le contenu voir sur un compte
pas trop de conneries mais pour
dépeindre la réalité il a fallu dépasser
la fiction et assister à des autopsies
cette fois-ci pour de vrai moi je vous
avouer que non
j'ai toujours refusé je suis très
sensible je tourne de lait très
rapidement devant les choses très très
réelles comme ça et puis dans les dans
les auteurs qui travaillent sur la série
les trois quarts l'ont fait ce voyage
pas tous et au niveau des comédiens
c'est vrai que nos deux comédiens
principaux ont assisté à des autopsies
pour les deux qui font les légistes ou
inciter à des autopsies ils ont pas tenu
en entier voilà ils ont pas tenu la
durée de l'autopsie complète ils ont
assisté au début et après ils ont vu
merci je pense que c'est plutôt
l'enquête criminelle qui interpelle dans
ces dans ces séries là
les questions qu'on pose par contre ou
lorsqu'on me dit je voudrais faire
médecine légale voilà je suis je suis en
troisième je voudrais faire médecine
légale bon je commence par leur dire bon
bah d'accord mais il faut d'abord être
médecin
ah bon je suis en Première je voudrais
faire médecine légale oui d'accord mais
faut d'abord être médecin puis mettre ça
légiste il faut d'abord être un médecin
du vivant et après vous pouvez passer au
médecin de la mort quand j'ai de demande
de voir des autopsies aussi parce que ça
ça arrive très souvent
voir des autopsies là c'est un autre
phénomène parce que les gens savent que
ce n'est pas la technique scientifique
qui vont voir c'est vraiment le boulot
du légiste et là je crois que souvent ça
répond à des problématiques personnelles
je veux voir une autopsie parce que j'ai
besoin de comprendre quelque chose de la
mort que je peux pas trouver autrement
qu'avec un légiste
voilà qu'est-ce que je deviens après la
mort comment est mon corps après la mort
où se trouve mon âme
misère sociale
agression accident crime
la médecine légale est là pour éclairer
les moments obscurs
une pratique qui brise les tabous de la
mort pour raconter une histoire
l'histoire des derniers instants d'une
vie
[Musique]